[Music]
[Applause]
luna the fastest easiest way to buy
bitcoin
if you're just getting into crypto it's
the perfect place to start
[Music]
hey guys and welcome back to my show
it's 10 p.m here so i am pushing through
we're keeping up the energy and it's
gonna be really great have a really
interesting guest
before we bring on my amazing guest um
this is powered by
icon plus as usual so a really quick
news announcement for you so this week
icon has announced its btp working group
which will fulfill
icon's vision of becoming the go-to
interoperability blockchain and crypto
by the end of 2021
so lots of competition for this spot at
the moment so that's going to be really
interesting to see how it plays out
now this is um sponsored by blockbuy you
can actually get up to 250
if you sign up i use them you can also
get up to i think it's about 8.6
interest they might change those i can't
remember but they're really cool i use
them so i'd recommend them um so
joining me today is a really cool guest
somebody that i've only recently gotten
to know
from the other side of the crypto
community it is
crypto eddie what's up how are you doing
hey hey leia nice to see you hey
how are you thank you for inviting me
onto your channel i'm
i'm great you know we are on opposite
ends of the world so for me it's
a little after seven in the morning so i
feel like
yes i'm up early and it's going to be a
very productive day
good i love that i think it's insane
that we are on opposite ends
of the world right now because i'm
telling my friends that i've got a show
and it's 10 p.m at night and they think
i'm absolutely nuts
and i said i'm speaking to somebody all
the way in japan and
they think it's crazy that we can do
this in the community yeah there's
really no
time in crypto at all in in terms of uh
geographic location zero zero
yeah it's insane and that's i think that
was actually one of the first things
that hit me when i joined this space
i it's like a saturday night for me once
and i remember somebody was just
messaging me
like trying to book in interviews and
work and i'm like what is happening
right now it's the weekend
and it's you know midnight but you know
it's uh it's the time for someone
somewhere there is
there is no weekend anymore is what i've
learned
and you lose track of days you don't
even know which day it is
and the other thing too which is maybe
maybe it's just me but you hear the the
people that do ta
yeah and they say the daily clothes well
we gotta hit the daily clothes i'm like
oh wait
i still don't get that at all and i
under
i understand what they're saying but
really it doesn't apply anymore
crypto is 24 7. so they're in
and it's in it's uh you know i'm 17
hours ahead of most of the world so
there is no daily clothes anymore i
don't get it
no you're absolutely right it's
literally not but i actually have fun
with that sometimes because like when
bitcoin is like reaching you highs or
something like i can sort of say it
happened
today and everyone's like no it happened
yesterday and i'm just sort of i like to
play with it
um but i've got an interesting plan for
us right now
and for our viewers so usually i keep
things quite
um structured um even though it's
probably nicer when it's more chilled
but it's just the way i mean
things quite structured but i'm gonna go
totally unfiltered
and i've asked you to bring two topics
and i've brought two topics
now i'll kick this off um because i have
a really interesting one
which i think everybody is going to
really enjoy and i think
you and i might be a little bit aligned
on this um so usually i wouldn't talk
about this
but i'm going to take it from a
different angle
so i'm going to forgive me for saying
these words because it's just not like
me but i'm going to talk about women and
crypto
oh yeah no yeah i hate i hate
i hate it i don't know very often but it
but
but maybe sometimes we should yeah
yeah well hang on before you get there
see my angle first see my angle
okay so women in crypto women in
industries women in is sort of a term
that
we just see thrown around all the time
now i don't know if i should get into
this at 10 pm i've got to make sure i
articulate myself correctly
um as to not offend anyone um but
i want to talk about it and i really
want to get your opinion on that kind of
stance
and whether firstly you know
we need women in you know do we really
need women in
i'll start with that what are your
thoughts on that
well we need more people and so the
if you're gonna separate men from women
the women are still
underrepresented up you know they're
just not represented like the men are so
um i guess we don't need them because
of the differences in in the way they
think or the
or the way they they approach life
i don't think that's why we need them
but i think that we need them
in to make sure that they are inclusive
i feel
bad that that many of them are missing
out
especially those that possibly don't
have a partner who has
brought them into the space because i
understand some women
are involved but just not engaging
with uh conversations on twitter or
what have you but they're not missing
out because they've got someone else
that's
that's uh in the space some way somehow
but what i feel bad for are the women
who are not
don't have any exposure to crypto that's
that's
that's horrible and so that just
again adds to the separation
of the haves and the haves have nots
and and that worries me that women are
missing out
on one of the greatest transfers of
wealth that we're going to see
in a very long time and
it's going to occur and it has occurred
actually it has occurred already and
look how many people have missed out
so that worries me so i guess the simple
one line yes no answer to your uh
question is yes we do but it's not
because
we're we're different it's because i
don't want women
to miss out yeah i think there's two
parts there
so i tend to agree with you when we talk
about i don't
necessarily think women bring anything
different just because
they're women i i really don't i think
you know people are so
diverse and so complex that
their value goes far beyond their gender
um
i'm never offended when knowing that
there's more men in the space i think
that
it's sort of just natural and i get a
bit frustrated
seeing people push women down paths
which i think
from a biological standpoint they're
sort of let's you know generically less
interested in
but in terms of giving women exposure i
think it's a really interesting point
so somebody was talking about gun rights
to me
and they said gun rights are a woman's
right
and i thought that was really
fascinating um
whether your programs or not whatever
but i thought that was really
fascinating
just because i could sort of understand
that you know in terms of protecting
women empowering women
and i sort of feel a similar way to
crypto because of what you're saying in
terms of that
that wealth and that that that
generational wealth and that that kind
of
move um because i think one of the
things
that is so important for women is i hate
seeing women trapped
because they don't have um they don't
have wealth and then
they're not able to let's say you know
do what they want pick a man that they
want
because they feel like they have to
follow you know wealth or money or
whatever it is
so i guess you know it financially
empowers women so from that standpoint
i like it yeah the last thing you want
to see is people
not make decisions to improve their life
in terms of being happy
uh because financially they can't afford
to
and so that is that's that's
and that happens typically more often
with women
especially those women who have children
because they
are really driven to be a caretaker
and so they their energy is is just
wiped out in terms of time and focus
and they really you know it's it's it's
just that much more difficult so
yeah it's it's in how and i've never
really approached like how am i going to
change that because
i don't believe that that should be
something i try to do i just try to do
my own
thing and actually my world is i feel
it's genderless to be honest with you
okay i i don't even remember half the
time
because i'm i'm actually i've been in
this
space in the working world for years and
years and years and years and it's
always
always the field that i have been in has
always been
predominantly male i mean it's been
always 80 percent
and or more and so i i guess i just
don't
think i don't think in terms of gender
believe it or not
i really don't but i think that it's
really a shame if if the women
are left out yeah
and yeah the women that are following me
by the way
i i you know i i do do take
notice and they are older and i don't
know if that's just because i'm older
or if it's just because they have
matured in their in their line
of investments you know
but it's i don't have a lot of young
when i'm talking young i mean
you know we we all know when we have a
youtube channel that google breaks down
our analytics for us on our back side so
we see a lot it's not like we're
guessing we actually see the numbers
that come
and we see that you know the the
20s and the 30s and the 40s and the 50s
and the 60s
they break it down for us right i
i don't know about you but what is your
percentage of women
have you looked lately on your analytics
where are
you absolutely tiny it's tiny it's
mainly men
and and i'm really okay with that i'm
beyond okay with it
because i like i said i'm never offended
by it and there's this huge
push to bring more women in and i just
to put it bluntly i don't think it's
that deep
you know as they say like i don't think
it's that dramatic
um i think like we're talking about
before i think it's amazing to empower
people
give them financial freedom um and you
know like you were saying
women sometimes have a harder time you
know naturally taking on the role of the
caretaker
for their kids and whatever and so you
know having that that kind of passive
income is
so liberating um and amazing
um but i just i get so frustrated
and you know here's a funny thing as
well i think i'm quite vocal about
it i think i'm quite vocal about my
stance on it and i get people reaching
out to me
saying hey we should work together we
you know we need more women in
i love your content and i'm like i'm
like don't try and connect with me
no i run from that i run
it's really rare that that you and i
have
connected now the second time because
it's just it's just super rare because i
don't do it because
i have an agenda to bring in more women
or that i i just don't do it it's just
not my
in fact i even get a little i even get a
little
uh don't do that when i see the
oh you know the most you see the list
coming from media that says the most
influential women in crypto or the
or the uh you know i just was like
why do we have to why do we have to do
that
why well here's a dilemma here's a
dilemma somebody actually
um featured me in an article as a woman
in
and you know like i'm a nice person and
i appreciate that i thought that was
really kind
so i was like i was like do i retweet or
do i not do i retweet or do i ignore i
was like right now i have to like
i retweeted it because you know it was
nice to be included so i was like
whatever
yeah i mean i was invited to participate
in
the binance finance has a has a yeah
yeah you probably know about it i can't
do it because i i still
am um a u.s citizen and so i'm i'm
unable to participate in that group but
i even have trouble with that you know
it's like
i understand what they're trying to do
but
it i think in in at the end of the day
it just
provides more division and more
separation and that's what i don't like
yeah i totally agree with you and i
think this idea is exactly the same when
it comes to race
and obviously i'm not black so i find it
really hard to i feel a bit
uncomfortable
talking about this but i as a woman i do
feel like it's the exact same
idea just you can literally just follow
through the ideology
in that it's almost i find it almost
insulting and almost patronizing to be
chosen based on my gender and saying
like
okay let's do something nice for the
ladies it's like no no
that's actually insulting that you think
that we need something nice like just if
you really want to
if you want equality then treat me as an
equal don't make a nice little cute
um you know little show i was like nah
it's okay like i can make my own show
you know what i mean and yeah i mean
here's an interesting one and then then
we'll move on top and then we'll move on
to the topics
um a lot of people talk about nature
versus nature
and a lot of people will say well no
women would be more interested if it
wasn't for social programming you know
like men are given bob the builder um
wait do you
you're not bob the builder is or is that
a british thing is it an icon that
he's kind of a muscled out guy and real
madrid
i don't know it's funny i just realized
it was british that's so funny um
it's it's like like an action man you
know action man yeah
oh you know okay good i'm just making
sure um okay yeah so it's like an action
man it's basically encouraging boys at a
young age you know like
you're bob the builder you build you're
strong and then women get like dolls and
babies and we get like the
processor barbie yes i'm sorry yeah i
i see okay so is it an action figure
that's sold in the uk
no bob the builder is um a tv show
actually um
but it's a bit bit like they'd sell the
merch
and you know boys would be i'm bob the
builder you know it's not like it's not
like
chloe it's probably chloe the cleaner
not chloe there or chloe the chef not
chloe the builder which is also fine so
my question is sorry
my question is is it nature versus
nurture or is this actual like
programming from a young age which has
then
made us choose different things
well i think it's a little of both
i think it's a little both i think we're
definitely a you know product of our
environment for sure
and a product of how we get pushed
into certain roles but i also think
there's a there's
there is something to be said about
you are you know you're you're born that
way so i think it's a little
both i don't think it's so easy it's
it's much more complex than that
i totally agree with you i do think it's
a bit of both um but what i can say
is i have two older brothers and so when
i was younger i definitely went through
a phase of
wearing boy clothes and i didn't i
don't play with barbies i play with
action man you know i i watch
wrestling and all that stuff because my
brothers were interested in that
but as i got older and i actually became
into myself
i started to become far more feminine
because you can't really fight biology
yeah that's where you are who you are
and then
yeah and then the other thing i think
sometimes girls do go through that
period where they try to
uh compete with boys to almost just have
you know proving to yourself that you
can do it
i remember playing flag football with
the boys i hated the football game
but i wanted to play the flag football
because i wanted to show the guys
i can you know i can be as well as they
can
so uh yeah i just think it's so
much more complex than than
i but i but i wish we paid less
attention to it is what i guess i'm
saying
which is why i don't like the i don't
like the list
i don't like the campaigns i don't like
the narrative behind it
i don't even like when i get on the
backside of twitter and i'm in a
you know we have sometimes we have
backside twitter groups right and
um if you make yourself known you'll
hear comments like oh clean up the
language we've got a lady in here
and i'm thinking to myself you should
hear me think i'm terrible
so that almost then takes away my right
to be able to
to use whatever language i want to use
because it's considered
that it has to be cleaned up because i'm
because you know oh we got a woman in
the house we got to clean up the
language
i just all of that just drives me crazy
yeah i'm totally with you and i think
when it comes to
kind of these differences overall the
more we talk about it and the more we
make a big thing about it
the more we perpetuate it i mean i mean
we can just look at like
america is just so funny as an example i
mean they literally have
black only spaces to make to to make it
like a safe space
yes like in parts of college campuses
yeah to make it like a safe space
um which is which is which is literally
taking you back to the 60s it's
the same result different intentions but
the same result
and we're still segregating we're still
you know it's still an issue and i think
kind of like the only way to get over is
just not talk about it just to move
forward basically
um well i don't know why you would do
that so so if you had a
space take take anything else
out let's say you are um asian and you
have an
asian faith a safe asian space and then
what happens if then you end up marrying
somebody
who is completely you're a traitor
yeah and then and then your child
is is automatically if you if you
promote that separate spaces and if you
have children
then your child is actually out
there's no there's no there's no space
you know so i i don't i don't understand
why people would
support that i don't understand it i'm
with you and i think
the biggest issues that um people who
are um
mixed race find they don't know where
they belong um
i mean my cousins are actually mixed
race and i know that
i know that and and they're mixed with
religion and it's a lot
and i know that they're beautiful and
everything they're
just growing up i think they definitely
weren't sure where they belonged because
they didn't belong there but they didn't
belong there and
it's a shame um and it and it's crazy so
i think
it's an interesting topic and i think
you know we massively agree which was
really cool
when i sort of noticed you're like
liking some of those things i wrote and
i was like ooh
we're on the same page i like that um
but i asked you to bring
a topic so hit me with it
so i just looked this morning i had one
actually last night
that i had in mind and then i re-read
that you said bring two so
i had to think of another one and that
one i'm gonna bring up now and i looked
on the
you have the most interesting tweets
lately i mean
your tweets the style of your tweets i'm
usually way too wordy
i'm always trying to put way too much
into
the space and you've got it down to
where you are
you are just pin pointing
your point in a probably less than
six or seven words it's a real i can't
do it
so i really admire and and you're always
just
really for me at least you're hitting
you're hitting very hot points of
topics for discussion and for critical
thought
and the one that you put recently was
what's the worst financial decision you
made and what's the best financial
decision you made
and when you actually have to ask
yourself that
wow that's a that's a big one to talk to
think about and it wasn't so easy for me
to do it because i think
you start to look at like maybe
something that you bought
that required maintenance for example
like now that i live in
in tokyo i don't have to own a car and
so i think gosh
owning a car was one of the worst
financial decisions
i ever made because of the maintenance
and of the insurance and of the gas and
everything i mean
you know so but what i really think
was the worst financial decision
i have made many times in my life
is to align yourself or to spend time
on people who are very difficult
to maintain a friendship with and what i
mean difficult
is that they they grab your focus away
from what you're really trying to focus
on
they suck you full of ener you know your
energy
because you're always trying to make
them happy
you know it's the people who are always
complaining about something or they're
they're always having some drama in
their life and
eventually you realize that
that's the way they are on a daily basis
and they're depriving you of i think a
lot of
happiness and so the worst
decision financially is to remain
friends with those people and spend time
in and the best decision and it's the
hardest
is to move on it's really brutal
but you have to really choose who you
who you spend your valuable time
with and on so that yeah
no i think it's brilliant um you are i
say this every single day you are
absolutely a product of i think at least
what did they say the five people you
spend your time with um
and i think and i was talking to
somebody earlier i think
when you're in this space or you know
when you when you're ambitious or you
have a dream or
whatever it is or you know you think for
yourself or you want to do things a bit
differently it can be a bit of a lonely
path to take
um because not everybody sees the world
the way you see it
um even right now politically you know
we're so divided you know the
conversation we just had is a
conversation that
i probably couldn't have with a lot of
my friends um they would you know they'd
be very like obviously we need women in
you know
it's on a very surface level you can't
really be like but why
um so i i'm i'm definitely with you and
i think
that's actually hard though isn't it
because you have to i was about to
i was like would you rather be alone
or surrounded by the wrong people right
how do you feel about that oh i'm
totally i guess i'm one of those people
i am completely comfortable with being
alone i'm the type of person i can go to
dinner by myself
you know can you do it it's easy for me
actually yeah i mean i've done a lot of
lunches by myself because i've lived in
a lot of foreign cities
on my own so i've done a lot of like
wine like you know
imagine like the french style like wine
and like a vogue you know posh cigarette
the way they
you know i tried that one out and that
was um
but yeah i mean i i'm with you i love my
own space
i'm actually moving house i'm moving
countries but
um i was trying to decide whether to
live with somebody or whether to not
live with somebody
and i was about to choose to live with
this girl
there's this terrace it's huge you know
it's amazing
i literally panicked i panicked so much
because i feel like people's energy rubs
off on me
really easy really easily um
and i just i like who i am and i just
want to like protect
my energy and so i'm really conscious
of being with other people um because i
just i really like to spread out and
like
you know the way i'm doing like this
with my arms like i just like want to i
can't even
verbalize what i'm trying to say i like
to express myself and i i would worry
living with someone that um that i
couldn't
yeah it's added stress it's like do you
take a vacation alone or you take
a vacation with someone and i i i can do
both
but i have just as much fun going alone
you know
it's easier it's easier it's just easier
it is you don't have to answer to anyone
you can go for dinner when you want to
go for dinner
you can stay out as long as you want to
stay out you know you don't have to
think about anyone i mean like i was
saying when i
was thinking about living with someone
what if i want to have a bunch of
friends over
like i'm very social you know get
everybody over
have a big barbecue i'd hate to ask
someone for permission
right hate it yeah so
so i i imagine you decided to go
go to you know live alone and you're
gonna move out of the country while
you're going to a new country have you
ever lived in this country before that
you've chosen
no i've never lived there i've been a
bunch of times on holiday but i've never
lived there but to be honest like
i just i just totally need it i just i'm
in the uk right now and it's too cold
for me um the cold makes my heart cold
um so yeah so yeah it'll be it'll be
really good
um but i i'm totally with you i think
you know you have to be so careful you
surround your who
you surround yourself with and sometimes
it means walking a
lonely uh path but it is what it is
isn't it
yeah i guess i just don't see it as the
lonely path
yeah i just don't see it that way i just
see it as uh
i'm tired of trying to compromise and
set my you know set my life back uh
based on trying to take care and
you know help people who can't be helped
you know i've you you try but
there are some people who just choose to
go to that
you know unhappy lots of drama
always have a problem and and then
it takes your time and that's what the
financial part that's what i'm saying
is that finance financial financial
success
is based on how much time you have for
us
right now in crypto time is really
really important because we have to do a
lot of research
and if you don't have that time
to devote to the space to make good
decisions
well then you're going to get
financially burned so
that's that's why i see the connection
of opportunity costs of uh spending time
with shitty people
there you go it is
it's out you're yeah you're absolutely
right um you know i think
it it it's just especially you know
even when you're trying to bring people
into crypto
and you sort of say to them trust me you
know you really want to do this you
really want to get this and
having to go over the same thing and the
same thing in the same thing and some
people just don't want to some people
don't want to learn some people don't
want to take risks some people just
don't want to hear it
um you know i've had that so many times
when i'm trying to help people with
their career
like i think social media is just so
important as we've seen
and um you know i know people who are
trying to do this and trying to do that
and i'm like please leverage social
media
there's only so many times i can say it
and then then you know the opportunity
cost kicks in and it's like okay i gotta
get back to work
yeah right yeah you will it's that whole
you can lead a horse to water but you
can't make it drink so
i don't even do the leading to the water
anymore
you have absolutely had enough i love
that but speaking of bringing new people
in
um this was another topic i wanted to
chat to you about we can go briefly over
this one to be honest but
um nfts i really wanted to get your
opinion on it because they're really hot
um i think two minutes ago i read so
nobody quote me on this okay
i saw on bloomberg maybe new york
new york times or new york post i don't
know i'm not american
um they put out an article about nfts
and then they made it into an nft
so so like this thing is going
mainstream
um i wondered what your thoughts were on
it do you think it's a bubble
or do you think um you know there's
actual useful technology here beyond the
bubble
i think a couple of things because i
have a
background in high-resolution digital
images that
uh from a world of art publishing and
what i'm seeing in a lot of these nfts
is
the violations of intellectual property
sometimes and many times you're going to
see images
that that person doesn't have the right
to use especially when you use it
in the form of making money on it and so
nobody's clearing the rights
on these images now people
totally that was all his work he made
one image
every day by himself five thousand days
in a row
no problem but if you go and go through
wearable or if you go through
uh open c you can see the use of
many many images like in montages and
collages and
and they the people who are
selling that don't have the rights
they have not cleared the rights with
either there are rules
in in the world of how long
an image belongs to the artist
and france has actually defined for us
in this world
up to 70 years and then if that
artist dies the family has the rights to
continue a foundation to protect the
rights of that artist and
so you see a lot of great artists that
were in the turn of the century
or um they haven't fallen into public
domain
because they still have the rights being
maintained by
by a family foundation so that's one
thing i see
and that hasn't blown up yet and i know
that there are a lot of intellectual
property
attorneys out there that are getting
contacted
and and i think you're going to see a
lot of lawsuits
so that's that's one point that i have
that i think
the people who are not in the space of
images
you know this is the first time that the
mass masses have been brought in to buy
images and they don't understand
intellectual property rights okay so
that's one
second thing is i think that the the
nfts as they are today
are not going to be the nfts that we see
a year or two or three or four download
i think it's going to
evolve and it's going to be
for example i think that technology is
going to allow us to
to actually create
nfts that have technology
in them that include more than just
maybe an audio file
but but more data is going to be you
know it's going to go to a next level
so that if you wanted to for example
cherry blossom season right now and i
take a picture of a
really beautiful blossom but what i want
to do is i also want to
embed the surrounding
audio for that so that somebody can say
oh my gosh i've got this image of the
you know in terms of a uh let's say a
short video
but in addition to that short video i
can hear the audio of
people walking uh and talking and so
you've got these
conversations that are going and i just
think that the the whole
experience of an nft is going to be way
way more than just
a static image or a short video
yeah i think it's going to totally
change i don't think it has
sustainability
with the way it is right now
yeah i think so going back to your first
point about regulation i think
that one's really interesting because
i've seen um you know people's tweets
being minted as nfts and sold um
surely there has to be some issues
regarding intellectual property i mean
if somebody took one of my tweets
don't do anyone watching
you know i'd be a little bit frustrated
so i'm sure there's some issues
surrounding that i don't know which
jurisdiction
gets involved i don't know how it works
yeah new laws will be
created because this is a space that is
new
so you're you're going to have attorneys
that actually take it to the courts and
then
there will be rulings and then it'll be
like you can't
ever take anybody's tweet you can't ever
take anybody's
um image without their permission or
you have to license it you know yeah all
those
all those new rules and laws will be
formed
out of this yeah no oh absolutely and
we're already seeing that happen
crypto now in general right um but what
the way i look at it
is okay so i think like the nft digital
art situation
is a bubble in my opinion i think
there's value but i think it's a bubble
in that right now it's just blowing up
but
the idea that you can verify something i
think is fantastic
yeah so maybe i'm looking at this like
really in a 2d kind of way
but i've said this before but i really
look at the value of nfts coming from
like
physical things like if you have a rolex
watch or
a handbag or like you design a product
and then you can you know actually
verify and know um you know whether it's
real or not because fakes are getting so
um they're getting so advanced to the
point where they're not even a fake they
just came out of different factories
but basically yes the same factory but
different uh different vans so the
supply chain is just different
um somewhere on that chain right so i
think that's gonna be really interesting
um and you know talking about advancing
it i also think you know house deeds um
i think i saw somebody sent me today um
let me get it on my phone actually i can
get it up somebody told me
that um an nft of a digital house
has just been has gone up let me see if
i can find it here we go
so mars house the world's first nft
backed virtual home sold for more than
000 pounds a virtual home that you can't
even
live in it's gimmicky it's
it's not the bubble though is that the
bubble yeah i mean
i mean it's fun for people to be a part
of that
because and i think and i think also the
people who are buying
at these crazy prices it's also like
again i'm just going to take you back to
a situation in japan at the first of the
year
always at new year they auction off a
big tuna
and that tuna is like kind of setting
the precedence for
the market for the new year and it it'll
sell for like
unbelievable amount of money like you
know like a million dollars for a blue
tuna
and yeah and the guy who
oh i think
yeah can you hear me
yes yeah
is it me or is it you you're you're
perfect you're not lagging
you're not lagging can you hear me oh
there we go i think we're back
yeah you were perfect i can't hear you
can you hear me
yes you can hear me yes okay i can't
hear you
maybe it's me bear with me one sec let's
have a look audio
i didn't mute myself mike speakers
testing i don't know can you guys let us
know in the comments if who you can hear
guys let us know if you can hear me
because arie i can't hear you eddie i
can't do it
i you're fine and i don't show muted
i don't know why you and me
oh you can hear both of us that's cool
they can hear both of us
but i'm the only one that can't hear oh
i can hear you now i can hear you now
okay okay wait no it's cut out let's cut
out let me take these out
okay i can hear you okay i think i know
what it is
there we go yeah maybe it's my my
rubbish airpods i actually dropped them
on the
on the floor before before we started so
there we go i'm sorry i missed what you
were saying we were talking about the
house and how that's the bubble
yeah and so i think that um the people
who are buying these at crazy prices are
doing it for marketing
in my opinion they're bringing attention
to themselves and then
if they can use it as a line item to
write off
uh it's just becomes a a marketing
expense
you know you can you can turn that
purchase into a marketing
expense that you you can justify oh i
purchased this to give myself some
exposure
because i needed to have um
you know a a window
to advertise myself my product or
whatever so i think some of these prices
are being driven by just people who have
money
that want to bring attention to
themselves and it's a form of marketing
so that's
that's where i think some of these high
prices are coming from yeah i mean
justin sun is the perfect
example of that what did justify
he he didn't he like offer well firstly
he was he's always putting like millions
down i can't remember how much he put
he offered on the people thing maybe he
put down like a few million
um and then he you know the warren
buffett thing a few a few years ago
he's always putting down millions um but
what's your final topic tell me what's
the final topic
um i want to talk about micro
excellence have you heard i have not
so i didn't really know this term either
and it is a term that a lot of
athletes have used in their training and
you know really easily to be understood
is that it's about just improving
like a one percent from the day prior
to bring your excellence up to a level
where you are
going to just kill it and what the these
uh
trainers have learned is that if you
apply this micro
excellence in your life for even just
the simplest things that
the tasks that you do every day i'm
talking about
tasks like like laundry
or task like cleaning or
whatever it's the same it the same
outcome applies so
it's not about what you have
accomplished it's all about
how much have you improved on a day to
day by day basis
and so you know i think as content
creators i don't know about you but
but it's a challenge to keep your life
in balance um for
some of the jobs or some of the things
that you have to do that
uh you know i just give you one example
because you can you can tie it to
something that is as trivial as
and i'm going to give you a real example
so being a content creator has taken me
away from maintaining a garden
okay okay and i'm really sad about that
because i really really love to take
care of
of the plants and the flowers i just
want
you can't do both ah see that's that
balance
of time so i um unfortunately i
i you know everybody says well you have
it's your choice you're not exercising
why not it's your choice you can do it
but it it's life is always about trying
to find that balance
so i've got it i've got a balcony that's
full of
old potted plants that have died
oh that i know it's terrible and then
when you see it
and you think to yourself oh my gosh
this is going to take me
all day if not two days to clean up
so instead of trying to do it all at
once
you just every day attack it
like maybe just one pot i'm just going
to take one pot today
and then you dump out the dirt and then
that pot goes into either storage or
whatever whatever it is you want to do
with it
and then the next day okay let's let's
do one percent better than i did
yesterday
and the concept is is that when you take
those jobs that you just keep
putting off the simple tasks of of just
maintaining your life so that it has
balance and you can apply it to
your exercise your food you know how you
see some people they say
i really don't like vegetables but i'll
but i'll have one bite of a vegetable
today and then
next day i'll have two bites and you
know it's the same sort of thing
but what i found is that the concept of
this my you know this micro
excellence concept of just improving
your
day by one percent every day
really does work really does work
yeah i had no idea that it was called
micro excellence is that we said it was
that's what the athletes call it yeah
it's really interesting i totally agree
it's not something that i consciously
thought about um
but i'm with you because just in general
when you want to achieve something
sometimes it can be so daunting and it's
like looking at like these
really big steps you know these huge
steps that you have to climb which are
you know in front of you but if you just
take okay well i just have to do a small
step
we can do a small step you know we go to
sleep again we breath so then we eat
then the next day
i can do another small step you know so
i guess it is just
it's just small steps but i totally
agree with you in terms of you know
creating content and having to find that
balance
um and uh there's always
i don't know where the saying comes from
i'm too sleepy at this point to remember
but
there's a saying uh was uh you're only
as good as your last performance or
whatever it is you know
so i'm always like i'm terrible i'm
always like well i'm only as good as my
last video or my last tip top
you know if one tic top got half a
million views
but the only uh that one got to 2 000
i'm like well i'm only worth 2 000 views
you have to you have to find that
balance and what i would say though
is everything that we've had with this
pandemic has just thrown
balance just right off you know it's you
know the uk is still in lockdown i've
been in lockdown since
december and um which has been insane
um and there is no balance so why
you know why am i working at night well
because i
you know number one i like it but also
number two i don't have anywhere to go
so you know that totally throws that
balance off but and then it shows you
how much you need that balance
and i think that's something that i'm
kind of trying to figure out
well what like what's my plant pot
what's my garden right like what do i
want to ditch
that i can't that i can't do because you
just can't do everything
and it's really figuring out
what what what don't i need and what do
i need to prioritize basically isn't it
yeah the the the situation that
everybody's in in this world right now
has really
proven to well sure i think everyone's
been quite resilient
and and adapted pretty well
for working but i think people are
working more hours than they did when
they used to go to
an office yeah because you you're able
to actually work
all the time and people don't respect
the hours anymore of
like you know eight to five or yeah six
or whatever so
i think that we we are out of
our routine and i think the
new routines that everybody is in has
been a lot you know disruptive but at
the same time too
i'm really happy that we have found that
we can work
more from home yeah i think i think this
commuting business to uh and it's like
think about just the think about the
footprint that you make on
the environment for one for commuting
yeah
and look at all the wasted time
and look at all who's getting rich on
that
when when you are you are having to i
mean
especially women are trying to
always keep the good look it and you
know have have the right clothes
have the right makeup the time that it
takes to get yourself ready to go to the
office
the commute time itself the cost of
of of just you know the pure cost and
actually moving your body from from one
location to another
you you lose at least two hours out of
your day
you know i i just don't i just don't
think
working in the office was a good idea to
begin with i'm so glad that the world
proved to themselves
the business can still happen without
going to an office
now i understand if you're in commercial
real estate you know you're sitting on
empty buildings or people who are trying
to get out of their leases
and i understand the impact in terms of
of real estate commercial real estate
but i i i'm just so glad that a lot of
people proved
that we don't have to go into an office
that's crazy yeah i'm with you i think
the commute is the most revolting thing
that's ever been invented
okay i'm really passionate about that i
think
i obviously are from london so we know
about how the commute works you know
people can't afford to live in london so
they live on the outskirts and they have
to
travel an hour and a half in an hour and
a half out there's three hours of your
day
so i used to do a job as a journalist in
london it took me an hour and a half to
get in
and then i'd have a shoe so somebody
that i'd have to film
the other side of london so like i'd
rush into work
at like it took me an hour and a half to
get there and once i was there i had to
rush all the equipment to the other side
of london
rush all the way back like oh my god
like all day i'm just rushing
yeah quality of life
like you know especially in london i'm
sure it's probably the same in all these
major cities
in tokyo yeah you leave before the sun
rises
and you're back home after the sun has
set that is not quality of life
right and and some of those people doing
the commutes on the trains here
they have to stand the entire way can
you you can't even get a seat
okay is it expensive in tokyo
oh yeah it it it goes back and forth of
being one of the most expensive cities
to live in but if you're really you know
just i guess depends on which
neighborhood you want to be in and how
large of a space you want
uh but if you do get a good neighborhood
and and a large space
yeah it's one of the most expensive
cities in in the world i mean
people always people always tell me oh
well look at the prices in
in san francisco or look at the places
in in uh
another expensive cities like hong kong
singapore is very expensive
uh you know hawaii is very expensive
also norway is very expensive yeah so i
know there's
there's there's expensive cities all
over but
tokyo is pretty expensive but you can
live cheap here
it's just can you're just not going to
live in a convenient place
and you're not going to live in a big
place you're going to live in a in a
really tiny place
i think what annoys me is kind of um the
the lie that i told that we need to live
in a city in order to do well
so when i was younger i used to go on
holidays to let's say like beach towns
or whatever
and i when i fall in love with the beach
i fell in love with the ocean and the
weather and
everything and i i'd want to stay there
and then i'd say to myself well you know
nothing successful happens here or you
can't be successful living here you have
to live in a city and that's just
absolutely rubbish
um you know and i think we're going to
see a massive exodus from
these really expensive cities in the
next decade
um so yeah i think that's gonna be
fascinating they're already people are
already
you know moving out of big cities
and actually they're moving out of
states poor california is losing
tons and tons of people yeah well i
think that's what happens when
i won't get into it but i'm not
surprised it's a pretty liberal state
and unfortunately
the homelessness there is terrible i
mean my friends were telling me
when they go to san francisco i mean
i've not been i don't know i hear when
you go to san fran
apparently there are people just like
shooting up on the streets and
you know it's just not worth all that
money
yeah in that kind of environment i don't
know the homeless camps in la have
gotten really
um unbelievable you know it's really
it's so interesting they used to have uh
some of the parks used to have when i
first arrived here
homeless communities where they actually
got the mail delivered
to their to their yeah it's not
anything it was unbelievable but uh
then there was kind of a change in um
who came into to the local government
power and
they moved them all out and nike came in
and built a skateboard park and where
they used to live
and and it's just now yeah totally
changed but
um yeah california is really
especially southern california is really
really dealing with that
that's a that's a that's a whole nother
really complex
issue yeah i think the move that i'm
seeing everybody make down to texas down
to florida is just insane
um i'm following it but um sure the
people down in austin too are like
oh my god get these californians out of
here oh yeah i hear that i hear you have
democrats moving down to republican
states voting for the same policies
that were implemented up there so yeah
i'll see how that plays out it'll be
interesting but eddie i want to thank
you so much for coming
on it's been so good chatting to you
being so excited to do this
um because i just think we have a lot in
common i really like your work i love
your energy i love what you do on
youtube
you built something so incredible on
there so honestly
well done i'm following and i really
enjoy it where can people
get hold of you follow you find out your
work
yeah i i really um i wanted to say
though before
that is that i really want to thank you
for the most of the more important thing
leia is that um not so much should we
have more women in this space
what i really really think and i this i
feel very passionate about
is that yeah it's totally okay to be a
part of two different communities right
and and and i i i'm gonna love you no
matter what community you align yourself
with
but i think what's really really
important and i want to thank you for
that
is having this cross-communication where
where just because we are into different
projects
um actually i'm into your project it's
just
it's not the only project that i pay
attention to so
that's why i have a crypto eddy channel
and it's e-r-i and
and i have been covering this space in a
fairly wide sense i'm i'm not i'm not
you know
covering all the balls but maybe the top
within the top 50 projects that are out
there that have
real utility and that's what i'm paying
attention to
and then um yeah i'm i'm on twitter too
of course because
those two kind of go hand in hand
yeah absolutely i think all this
tribalism in my opinion is just
um
i don't i don't really think i fit in in
any community um i guess you could say
i'm a bitcoiner but
the maxis don't like me anyway so you
know that's that um
so because i i'm interested enough to
i'm interested i'm open-minded i'm
interested like
you know and that's what it is um but
yeah to me look
if people are cool and you can have a
good chat then i'm happy to have a good
chat no matter what coins you're holding
so thank you so much for coming on and
um i want to thank everybody for
watching and don't forget to tune in
next thursday
for another fabulous guest see you later
bye
[Music]
[Applause]